Wer ist der?
Ich bin der.
Dann können wir gleich ein paar Noten nehmen.
Er.
Howard.
Ö flumendot.
Für Nervenbüsta birien.
Ja.
A, L, A, L, D. Nachname Topf, T, O, P, F.
Danke. Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Topf?
Ich bin jetzt 37 Jahre alt.
Was sind Sie, Gunagiya Borun?
Siebter August 1984.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin ungefähr 1,80 m groß.
Wie viel wiegeln Sie?
Ich habe jetzt 65 kg abgenommen.
Wie viel haben Sie abgenommen?
Im letzten halben Jahr würde ich so knapp 8-9 kg schätzen.
Was für Beschwerden haben Sie?
Ich habe seit längerer Zeit Probleme im Bauch,
mit Bauchschmerzen und auch Durchfall.
Heute Morgen habe ich ganz starke Schmerzen bekommen
auf der rechten Seite unten im Bauch.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt ins Krankenhaus gekommen.
Sie haben Bauchschmerzen seit wann?
Leiden Sie unter December schwer?
Wenn man das genau nimmt, ist das schon über ein halbes Jahr,
wo ich immer wieder so Schmerzen habe im Bauch,
die kommen und gehen.
Dann habe ich auch Durchfall.
Dann gibt es mal Zeiten, wo ich keine Beschwerden habe.
Dann auch mal längere Zeiten, wo ich auch keinen Studiengang habe.
Aber es kommt immer wieder so Schubweise,
dass ich diese Bauchschmerzen mit Durchfall bekomme.
Wie oft treten die Beschwerden auf?
Manchmal habe ich auch 1, 2 Wochen gar keine Probleme.
Dann gibt es wieder eine Zeit,
wo ich dann fast täglich diese Beschwerden habe.
Sehr unterschiedlich.
Wie lange dauert man die Beschwerden?
Teilweise mehrere Stunden.
Aber so stark wie heute Morgen war es nicht gewesen.
Deswegen bin ich heute ins Krankenhaus gekommen.
Wie fühlen sich die Schmerzen an?
Das sind schon kramfartige Schmerzen, die ich habe.
Dann habe ich oft dann auch Durchfall.
Dann lässt das ein bisschen nach.
Hauptsächlich so kramfartige Schmerzen.
Manchmal war es auch so dumpfe Schmerzen.
Aber eigentlich sehr oft ist es kramfartig.
Okay.
Sie haben auch Durchfall.
Wir sind aus Iristul.
Wenn ich Durchfall habe, ist es auch kramfartig.
Manchmal war es auch so dumpfe Schmerzen.
Aber eigentlich sehr oft ist es kramfartig.
Okay.
Sie haben auch Durchfall.
Wir sind aus Iristul.
Wenn ich Durchfall habe, ist es fast wie Wasser manchmal.
Ein bisschen Schleim ist auch dabei.
Aber ist sie westlich.
Westlich.
Es sieht dann auch teilweise unverdaut aus.
Das ist so.
Das unverdauten riecht übel.
Übel riechende.
Okay.
Haben Sie darin Blut gesehen?
Blut habe ich nicht gesehen, nein.
Ich habe noch nicht gesehen, nein.
Ich habe schon nicht gesehen, nein.
Ich habe nicht gesehen, nein.
Die ist im rechten Unterbau.
Der Schmerzen.
Das ist im rechten Unterbau.
Die Schmerzen.
Heute Morgen habe ich das nur da unten.
Aber es gibt auch mal Schmerzattacken.
Wo ich das auch in der Mitte vom Bauch spüre.
Oder auch mal unten im Bauch, in der Bauchmitte.
Das ist ein bisschen besser, aber so richtig helfen tut das auch nicht.
Ich habe schon mal mit Paracetamol probiert und auch Buscopan, aber das hat alles nicht so viel geholfen, fand ich.
Ich habe immer versucht, das selbst zu behandeln.
Es war auch noch nie so schlimm wie heute.
Heute Morgen dieser Schmerz, der ist 7, 8.
Der ist jetzt auch nicht mehr so gut wie früher.
Ich habe ja auch abgenommen, wie ich schon gesagt habe.
Der ist nicht so gut.
Eigentlich nichts gemerkt bisher.
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich nicht heiß an.
Normalerweise habe ich keine Fieber.
Wenn die Schmerzen ganz stark sind, habe ich auch Übelkeit.
Ansonsten würde ich sagen eher nicht.
Als aktuell nichts war nur so leicht Übelkeit gewesen.
Eigentlich nicht, nein.
Schlafen sehr gut.
Früher hatte ich keine Probleme, weil ich schon Schlafstörungen habe.
Aber früher hatte ich keine Probleme.
Was ist das für dich?
Vor einigen Jahren ist es festgestellt, dass ich Morbus-Bechter-Ref habe.
Das hat die starken Glengschmerzen auch im Becken, im Kreuzbein und in der Hüfte.
Da ist die Diagnose Morbus-Bechter-Ref gestellt worden.
Aber aktuell habe ich keine Beschwerden.
Ich habe nicht mehr Schmerzen.
Ich habe noch Physiotherapie gemacht.
Seitdem habe ich keine Beschwerden und keine regelmäßigen Medikamente dafür.
Ich habe eine Fistel und einen Abszess im Ampou.
Das war vor einem Jahr ungefähr.
Ich hatte auch Magenbeschwerden.
Mein Haushalts-Mann untersuchte mich.
Ich hatte Probleme auf der Arbeit.
Da war ich von meiner Stimmung nicht so gut.
Ich hatte eine depressive Verstimmung, sondern ich habe auch eine Medikamente aufgeschrieben.
aufgeschrieben dafür.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie ein?
Sehr trahlien nehme ich ein.
Okay, Sie haben Sie sind beigun abse operiert worden.
Ich möchte auch fragen, haben Sie underhaut,
Irgendwelche Veränderungen?
Underhaut habe ich es nichts gemerkt, nein.
Haben Sie Algun Probleme?
Auch nicht gemerkt, nein.
Okay, abgezählen von Morbus 5-Terev,
haben Sie gelenks Schmerzen zum Beispiel,
handgelenk?
Jetzt nicht, nicht.
Ich habe keine Schwere.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie abgezählen zertralen?
Also, als ich diese Magenschwerden hatte,
hat mir der Hausarzt auch Pandoprazol gegeben.
Das nehme ich nur ab und zu ein,
wenn ich Schmerzen im Magen habe und das auch refluxgeschwerten habe.
Bye, Bedarf.
Zertralen in welcher Dosis nehmen Sie?
50 Milligramm.
Wie oft nehmen Sie am Tag?
Eine, eine pro Tag.
Ab und zu?
Ich nehme es mittags, nämlich.
Abgezählen von Abse,
wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Eigentlich nicht, nein.
Das war meine erste Operation.
Okay.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft, Herr Topf?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Also, ich habe zwei Impfungen.
Okay.
Sie gehen Corona auf zwei Impfungen.
Ach so, ich meine jetzt Corona.
Die anderen Impfungen weiß ich jetzt gar nicht mehr.
Also, abgehend bin ich durchgeimpft worden.
Seitdem habe ich jetzt keine Auffrischung gekommen,
aber Corona bin ich zweimal geimpft.
Okay.
Sind Ihnen allergen oder unverträglichkeit bekannt?
Nein, keine.
Rauchen Sie, Herr Topf?
Ja, ich rauche.
Ich habe geraucht, ich habe vor sieben Jahren aufgehört.
Davor habe ich einen Päckchen Zigaretten geraucht gehabt.
Wie lange haben Sie geraucht?
Also, ich habe mit 16 angefangen
und dann habe ich jetzt mit 30,
also, wie lange vor fünf Jahren habe ich aufgehört.
Bis 32 Jahre habe ich geraucht.
Also ungefähr 15 Jahre vielleicht.
15 Jahre?
Ein Päckchen.
Aber ich habe aufgehört, es war vor knapp fünf Jahren.
Ja, das ist sehr gut.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Also, in letzter Zeit eigentlich nicht mehr.
Da habe ich gemerkt, dass ich mich auch nicht so bekommt.
Also, eigentlich kein regelmäßiger Alkohol.
Das ist normal, aber jetzt,
zum letzten halben Jahr, ein Jahr,
bringe ich nicht keinen Alkohol.
Okay.
Selten.
Selben, ja.
Als Ihr erst dann, muss ich Sie fragen,
ob Sie irgendwann Drogen konsumiert haben?
Früher habe ich mal Drogen.
Also, es war so, wenn ich zu den,
zur Disco gegangen bin,
haben wir halt diese extra See-Tabletten genommen.
Das ist nur sporadisch.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie wichtige Erkrankungen,
zum Beispiel
Darm-Erkrankungen, Bekat?
Ja, mein Vater ist relativ jung am Darmkrebs verstorben.
Da war er so knapp 15 Jahre.
Ansonsten, meine Mutter ist gesund.
Ich habe zwei Geschwister, die jünger sind,
als ich, die sind auch gesund.
Also nur der Vater hatte diese Darmkrebs gehabt.
Wie alt war Ihr Vater?
55, ungefähr.
Hat noch gearbeitet gehabt.
Ja, Ihr Mutter ist gesund.
Ist gesund, ja.
Gott sei Dank.
Was sind Sie von Beruf, Herr Topf?
Also, ich habe gelernt, Einzelhandelskaufmann,
aber ich bin jetzt seit einem Jahr arbeitslos.
Und ja, deswegen habe ich auch so ein bisschen
psychische Probleme gehabt.
Sie sind verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin Single.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, ich war nicht verheiratet bisher.
Okay, Herr Topf, ich habe von meiner Seite
eine wichtige Frage gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen in diesem
Zusammenhang damit?
Ja, ich kann sagen, dass ich mich seit einem halben Jahr,
wo ich diese Beschwerden habe, auch sehr körperlich schwach fühle
und auch müde bin.
Also, das ist vielleicht noch eine Sache, die mir eingefallen ist.
Aber ich habe das Gefühl, dass Sie das Wichtigste haben,
das ist das Wichtigste, das Sie von mir gehört haben.
Okay.
Bitte nehmen Sie Platz im Wartes immer.
Ja.
Ich rufe Sie gleich, okay?
Alles klar, ich warte dann.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Tschüss.
So, gibt es Fragen
aus dem
von den Zuhörern?
Ich sehe jetzt nichts.
Alles Wichtige gefragt?
Haben Sie gemerkt,
im Mund oder im Gentiligen Region
Geschuhe haben?
Geschwüre?
Ja.
Ja, habe ich nicht gemerkt.
Okay.
Gut, also Sie meinen, so aften mein Sie, oder?
Ja, ja.
Alles klar.
Nee, hat er nicht gehabt.
Ja, eine gute Frage.
So, okay.
Ich glaube, die Anamese war ziemlich gut
und kompakt alles zusammengefasst.
Dann können wir zur
Oberarztvorstellung gehen, glaube ich.
Okay.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstagnose?
Morbus Crohn.
Mhm, gut, sehr gut.
Alles klar.
So, dann erzählen Sie mal dem Oberarzt,
das Sie beim Patienten gehört haben.
Hallo, Herr Oberarzt,
hätten Sie Zeit für mich?
Ich möchte Ihnen eine Patientin vorstellen.
Gerne, bitte schön.
Herr Harold Topf
ist ein Patient,
der 37 Jahre alt,
1,80 m groß,
65 kg schwer.
Der Patient hat sich
wegen seit einem halben Jahr
gesteckt.
Ich habe mich gefühlt,
und ich habe für mich
seine Mitnahme
vorhanden.
Ich habe die
Zeit für die
Anfang im Abstand ein bis zwei Wochen, aber in der letzten Zeit
die Abstand,
außerdem klagt er über Gewichtsabnahme von acht bis neun Kilogramm
inneralpt Zechs Monatsen und klagt er auf Fatigu, Antriplosik,
Depplesi, Schiedemung,
die vegetative Anamnese war auf der Leich in Bezug auf in Apatens und Schlafstörungen
und Übelkeit, ja, im Nausea, auf Gezirte,
und die Schuhe,
der Patient Leide,
seit Anderthalb jaren Ankylozan Spondilit,
der mit Physiotherapie behandelt,
Ankylozan Sponditis, ja,
aber ob es recht ist, lieber mit dem Fachbegriff,
dann kann man sich nicht so versprechen, ja.
Aus Erdham Leide er unter Magenbecher der Undepression,
die Medikamenten Anamnese ergabt eine Rekalmetzige Einnahme von
sertralinfektivemiligramm mittags,
bei Bedarf, Nehmeer, Pantoprosol, ein.
Korinemjar sei er wegen Abses operiert worden,
gegen Corona habe sie...
Abses wo, war der Abses?
Am Rektalarea.
Im Rektum, oder?
Glutealarea.
Ja, wie nennt man das auch noch, diese Bereich, gluteal?
Perianal.
Perianal, ja, ja, gut, ja.
Er sei gegen Corona geimpft,
bei ihm keine...
sein, keine allergenen Verträglichkeiten bekannt,
dann Nikotin Konsum, HBR,
For Zeibunyaren,
eingestellt,
da, da, Mals, HBR,
5 Seniare lang, ein Pekchinen,
ein Pakkuprotakt gerout,
Alkohol, Trinker, Zeltzen, Alkohol,
Drogen, HBR als Jungen probiert,
Interfamilien Anamnese,
Kauffman gearbeitet, als ein solcher Kind.
Okay.
So, die Verdachtsdiagnose haben Sie schon gesagt, ist Morbus Kron.
Wie kommen Sie darauf?
Warum denken Sie an Morbus Kron?
Morbus Kron ist die Klinik so eindeutig, seine Klinik?
Die Klinik ist 37 Jahre alt.
In diesem Alter trägt diese Krankheit.
Und bei Morbus Kron ist iliocecal, der Bereich ist betroffen.
Deswegen in rechten Unterrampenbau ist typisch für die Schmerzen,
bei Morbus Kron.
Und in Schupeweißen, in Schupeweißen, in Tretenbebüchwerden,
das fast auch Morbus Kron.
Und abseh, bei der Morbus Kron ist die alle Schichte,
den darm Betroffen.
Und können es auch an der Qualitys Ulsterosa sein?
Ja, im Differential Diagnostisch kommt Qualitys Ulsterosa infrage,
aber wir können mit Hilfe von Magenspiegelung, Darmspiegelung,
als Schillis, während dieser Unterzugsung können wir auf
GWB Probe entnehmen und als Schillis.
Okay. Kann man mit der Endoskopie immer ausschließen,
dass es Morbus, dass es keine Qualitys Ulsterosa ist?
Nicht immer, aber meistens.
Okay. Also Sie haben mich schon gesagt, Sie würden jetzt auch
eine Endoskopie machen, habe ich richtig verstanden, ja?
Ja. Was für eine Endoskopie machen Sie da?
Zuerst Koloskopie, aber bei Morbus Kron,
die müssen alle Gasventesinal Trakt beurteilen.
Okay. Worauf ist bei der Koloskopie zu achten,
wenn Sie einen Verdacht auf Morbus Kron haben,
also wenn Sie Koloskopie gemacht haben, Sie spiegeln hoch bis
über Ascendens in Zykalpol, was ist da zu beachten bei der Endoskopie,
Koloskopie? Was sollte man versuchen?
Absicht, oder Pistone?
Das können Sie sehen oder auch nicht sehen,
aber wenn Sie jetzt eine Koloskopie gemacht haben,
die ist unauffällig bis zum Zykalpol, ist das dann ausgeschlossen?
Wir müssen auch Magenspiegelung machen.
Magenspülffinger da, das machen Sie auch,
ist auch in Ordnung vielleicht, aber was ist bei der Koloskopie wichtig,
was man probieren sollte?
Das klappt nicht immer, aber sehr oft kann man das versuchen.
Das fällt mir nicht ein.
Man kann versuchen bei der Koloskopie in das terminale Ilium
vorzuspiegeln über die Bauhinsche Klappe,
dass man auch versucht das terminale Ilium einzusehen,
weil das ja die bevorzugte Stelle ist für Morbus Kron.
Aber manchmal, dann kann man manchmal, wenn im Kolon die Schlammert
unauffällig ist, kann man manchmal dann im terminal Ilium
eine Veränderung sehen, die man biopsieren kann.
Kann man probieren. Aber jetzt angenommen,
Sie haben Koloskopie gemacht, unauffällig,
das Koloskopie, was machen Sie dann noch?
Wir können mit paar Jung-CT machen
und wir können auch füßtel ausschließen
mit Hilfe von Kontrastmittel mit CT.
Was macht man bei jungen Leuten, macht man da CT?
Macht man da lieber etwas anderes?
Man ist nicht so alter Patient, 37 Jahre alt.
Und wenn er Morbus Kron hat, dann wird er oft noch Bilder
brauchen müssen vom Bauch.
Man würde MRT bevorzugten.
MRT nach Selling.
Früher hat man Röntgen nach Selling gemacht,
mit dem Kontrastmittel, wie Sie gesagt haben.
Mittlerweile macht man MRT nach Selling,
um einfach da diese Veränderung
oder auch füßtel zu sehen.
Was ist denn bei Morbus Kron
ein Unterschied zu Kolitis Ulsterosa
für einen Befallsmuster?
Ja, bei Kolitis Ulsterosa
ist es ein kontinuierer Muster.
Aber bei Morbus Kron
Das ist ein Kalturmtasche auf Türkischer Abbau.
Flasterschein, aber Sie können einfach sagen.
Flasterschein.
Es reicht doch, wenn Sie sagen, discontinuierlich.
Okay, jetzt haben Sie in MRT gemacht, also Koloskopie und Gaskopie waren unabhängig.
MRT, Diagnose ist nicht so eindeutig.
Es gibt noch weitere Untersuchungsmöglichkeiten, wie Sie dem nachgehen können.
Ja, manche gehen, gibt es.
Wir können auf diese Genutation untersuchen.
Das ist zum einen, aber Sie wollen ja meistens eine Diagnose stellen,
indem Sie historopathologisch etwas nachweisen.
Also eine Gedeleprobe meistens ist das beste.
Wie kommen Sie da dran?
Wie können Sie weitergehen?
Operieren Sie den Patienten?
Bei Morbuskron, die Operation wird nicht die Krankheit gehalten.
Wenn Patient Qualitis Hysterozivere kommt,
dann kommt die Operation infrage,
aber bei Morbuskron, wir versuchten Medikamente.
Konservativ, meistens, ja.
Manchmal kann man Operation nicht vermeiden,
in welchen Fällen muss man operieren?
By the complication.
Welche?
Absetzfistül, Müslender operieren, ja.
Absetzfistül, ja.
Ich wollte noch eine Sache noch fragen,
wenn Sie jetzt verdacht haben,
dass nur der Dünndarm befallen ist.
Sie haben Endoskopie,
das jetzt mit Koloskopie und Gasoskopie nicht gesehen.
Aber gibt es noch eine andere Möglichkeit?
Der Endoskopie, kennen Sie die?
Wie untersucht man den Dünndarm mit Endoskopie?
Kann man das untersuchen?
Kapsel und...
Kapsel, ja.
Was gibt es noch?
Schon mal gehört von einer...
Also man hat eine Enthoroskopie, ja.
Gibt es ja?
Ja.
Schon mal gehört Doppelballon, Enthoroskopie?
Nein.
Doppelballon.
Das ist ein Zentrum,
dass man den Dünndarm versucht zu untersuchen
mit Endoskopie, mit langen Endoskopen.
Mit Doppelballon, damit man die blockt
und dann besser vorspielen kann.
Eine Möglichkeit.
Gut, das war schon sehr gut.
Hab ich noch Fragen?
Also, was sind denn so...
Sie haben jetzt Diagnostik schon beschrieben.
Machen Sie noch andere diagnostische Maßnahmen,
um die Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen?
Ausseher ist der Gewebeprobe,
Endoskopie, MRT und so weiter.
Was macht man noch gerne?
Machen Sie auch Labo-Untersuchungen bei den Patienten?
Bei der Labo-Untersuchung
können wir es tun,
Parameter beurteilen.
Ja, genau.
Also, der Anglossonsfondilit
ja, diese Erkrankung
kann man mit einem sein.
Ja.
Das kann man noch getrennt untersuchen.
Es gibt ja verschiedene Untersuchungen,
TAL-AB 27 und so was.
Aber ich meine es so für den Morbis-Kohen,
speziell Labo-Untersuchungen.
Manche gehen mit der Situation,
gibt es bei diesen Patienten,
aber zurzeit fällt mir nicht ein.
Aber sonst so normalen Labor-Wert,
was gucken Sie nach?
Entzündung zu der HP-Werte?
Interessiert Sie der HP-Werte, die Anämie?
Ja, weil diese Patienten mal
Absorption bestätigt.
Deswegen, diese Patienten leiden an
Anämie und einige
Vitamine-Mandeln.
Das ist wichtig.
Jetzt haben wir noch im Chat noch ein paar Sachen gelesen.
Stuhlprobekalprotektin,
das ist auch eine Bestimmung, die man machen kann,
die auch Schlammertentzündung hinweisen kann.
Was gibt es noch für Kommentare?
ZTM-Methy,
ja, wir bevorzugen Methy, weil es junger Patient ist
und vermutlich im Laufe der Krankheit der Patientin
und der Sohn bekommen wird.
Die weniger Strahlenbelastung ist besser.
Autoantikörper, Aska,
das kenne ich beim Morbus-Kron nicht, aber kann sein.
Wie behandeln Sie die Krankheit?
Sie haben schon gesagt, konservativ,
Medikament püßt.
Welche Medikamente benutzt man da sehr gerne?
Sulfo Salazin,
...
richtig, ja, sehr gut,
okay.
Primär, so.
вел war das nicht
Es ist sehr gut.
Sehr gut.
Abi, du hast jetzt die beste Zeit.
Sehr gut, oder?
Man muss nicht in eine kurze Kursin gehen.
Die beste Zeit, oder?
Ja, das ist toll.
Ja.
Okay.
Wenn du keine andere Erfolge gibt,
dann kannst du die zweite Spiele passen.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht so.
Oder, danke dir.
Danke dir.
Ja, ich bin gekommen.
Guten Tag.
Fangen wir direkt an?
Wo sind wir?
Im Krankenhaus, Notaufnahme, ja?
Einverstanden?
Ja, einverstanden.
Okay, dann fangen wir mal an.
Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Takim Mesoglu.
Ich bin der Arzt.
Bevor wir anfangen,
muss ich Ihre persönlichen Daten notieren.
Und dann schieb ich mir über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden.
Ist das okay für Sie?
Ja, Doktor, ich habe zwar Luftmutter,
aber ich versuche, so gut es geht, Ihnen zu antworten.
Ah, okay.
Zuerst, wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Thomas Holz.
Herr Holz,
könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen machen?
Thomas T-H-O-M-A-S.
Ja.
Und Holz, H-O-L-Z.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Holz?
Ich bin jetzt 28 Jahre alt.
Okay.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
1. Mai 1993.
Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel liegen Sie?
Ich bin 1,85 m und wiege 68 kg.
Okay.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin der Arzt.
Ich bin der Beruf.
Ich bin Automechaniker.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin Single.
Okay.
Ich nehme an, Sie haben keine Kinder, aber...
Ich habe keine Kinder.
Aber Sie haben keine Kinder?
Nein, ich habe keine Kinder.
Also, Herr Holz,
was für Sie tun Sie?
Herr Doktor, ich habe es heute Morgen,
also vor drei Stunden,
etwa 40 starke Schmerzen bekommen in der Brust.
Und ich kann deswegen jetzt kaum noch atmen
und husteln und tief einatmen,
kann ich gar nicht mehr.
Und das wird so,
also mit jeder Minute schlechter habe ich das Gefühl.
Haben Sie Luftdott und husteln Sie auch?
Also, ich muss da so husteln.
Ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Also, jetzt, seit einer Stunde wird mir auch so ein bisschen schwarz verurgen, finde ich.
Also, ich fühle mich nicht gut und die Luftdott wird immer schlechter.
Und ich weiß nicht, ich muss vielleicht sagen,
dass ich vor zwei Wochen gegen Corona das erste Mal geimpft worden bin.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob es daher kommen kann,
wollte ich Ihnen nochmal gesagt haben.
Vor zwei Wochen haben Sie erste Dose gehabt?
Ja, erste Dose ist ja.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig oder übel?
Ja, also mir wird es schwarz verurgen ein bisschen.
Ja, also ich fühle mich nicht wohl.
Übel kann ich jetzt nicht sagen,
aber ich, beim Kreislauf ist irgendwie nicht gut.
Okay.
Haben Sie Ihr Bewusstsein verloren?
Nein.
Haben Sie auch Herzrasen oder Herzklopfen?
Also, ich glaube, mein Herz pocht auch schnell.
Ich glaube, ja.
Die Luft wird immer schlechter, Herr Doktor.
Können Sie mir da helfen?
Ja, natürlich.
Aber ich muss zuerst diese Fragen,
die sich gesprächsisch bis zum Ende führen.
Und dann natürlich...
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das schaffe, Herr Doktor.
Mir geht es nicht gut.
Okay.
Machen Sie sich erstmal keine Sorgen.
Nach diesem Gespräch helfe ich Ihnen sofort, ja?
Ja, Herr Doktor, mir wird schwindelig.
Ich muss, ich fall um.
Kann ich mich hinlegen?
Ja, natürlich, natürlich.
Können Sie...
Ich sitze schon, aber kann ich mich hinlegen
auf dem Boden jetzt oder was?
Ja, ja, natürlich, natürlich.
Okay.
Soll ich mir ja ein paar Minuten warten?
Wir können warten, aber es wird nicht besser,
Herr Doktor.
Ich glaube, es wird immer schlechter in der Luft.
Ja, ich kann kaum noch reden.
Okay.
Können Sie mir etwas geben,
dass ich besser Luft bekomme?
Vielleicht Sauerstoff oder so was?
Okay, natürlich.
Ich ordne sofort bei der Schwester an.
Okay, gut.
Okay, Sauerstoff hat schon ein bisschen geholfen.
Ja, geht schon ein bisschen besser.
Jetzt können wir weitermachen, ja?
Okay.
Okay, geht es Ihnen besser?
Herr Holsch?
Ein bisschen, ja.
Nicht gut, aber ein bisschen besser
als vor ein paar Minuten, ja.
Okay, können wir weitermachen?
Wir versuchen, Herr Doktor, soweit es geht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es schaffe.
Okay, okay.
Okay, dann...
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden
oder das war es?
Das ist das Wichtigste, alles andere.
Ich habe es jetzt vergessen,
indem ich ganz gestresst.
Ich habe jetzt eine Luftnot.
Luftnot, okay.
Okay, jetzt möchte ich ein paar Fragen
nach Ihrer Krankengeschichte stellen.
Ja, ja.
Leiden Sie an irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen,
wie zum Beispiel
Blutotorok oder Zuckerkrankheit?
Nein, Blutotorok ist nicht bekannt.
Zucker habe ich auch nicht.
Ich habe Lungenempfelsen
und auch COPD
hat man hausarzt
festgestellt.
Das war ein Lungenpfarrer-Arzt.
Deswegen nehme ich auch so etwas
zum inhalieren.
Mit Kapsel mache ich jeden Morgen
eine inhalation.
Okay.
Wie sind Sie den genauen Namen
vom Medikament?
Spiriva.
Wie oft nehmen Sie
von diesem Medikament?
Eine Kapsel morgens,
oder eine Kapsel morgens?
Okay.
Seit wann ist COPD bei Ihnen bekannt?
Seit ungefähr
4, 5 Jahren glaube ich.
Da hatte ich wegen Luftbesperren
einen Lungenpfarrer aufgesucht.
Er hat dann Lungen-Test gemacht
und hat dann gesagt,
ich hätte COPD
und hat dann auch nochmal
einen CT gemacht damals.
Da hat er gesagt, ich habe Lungenempfelsen.
Er ist ganz ausgeprägt,
und hat dann noch einen Lungen-Test gemacht.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Nein, sonst habe ich keine Erkrankungen.
Okay.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Als Kind am Bindern.
Da war ich 8 Jahre alt.
Und leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Mein Vater ist gestorben.
Er ist relativ früh gestorben.
Er ist ein Lungenkrebs.
Meine Mutter lebt noch.
Meine Mutter lebt noch,
aber die hat auch COPD am Herzen.
Sie hat verschiedene Krankheiten.
Mit welchem Alter ist Ihr Vater gestorben?
Das war knapp 60,
62 glaube ich,
war dann nicht ein Rente.
Herr Holt,
haben Sie Fieber oder haben Sie Fieber gehabt?
Nein, ich habe keine Fieber.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Angeln oder durchschlafen?
Bisher nicht, nein.
Okay.
Was ist das für eine Erkrankung?
Ist Ihr Appetit gut?
Und zum Beispiel,
heute Morgen haben Sie gut gefrischt?
Ja, normal.
Also keine Änderung.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang
oder beim Wasserlass?
Auch nichts, das ist alles normal.
Herr Holt,
fühlen Sie sich gestrissen
oder nicht gestrissen?
Die man jetzt schon,
aber sonst nichts.
Und außer
CP-Riva nehmen Sie
Regenmessig oder bei Bedarf mit
Kamente ein? Nein, nein.
Okay. Rauchen Sie?
Ja, leider.
Wie viel rauchen Sie und seit wann rauchen Sie?
Also ich habe mit,
vielleicht auch mit so 16, 17 angefangen
und
ein bis zwei Paction pro Tag.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nicht regelmäßig,
also vielleicht am Wochenende mal,
wenn ich mit Freunden zusammen bin,
sonst nicht regelmäßig.
Nehmen Sie sonst die Drogen?
Also früher mal
jetzt nicht mehr als
Jugendliche habe ich auch Drogen
konsumiert, aber das war nur so
zum Spaß.
Okay. Und sind bei Ihnen
irgendwelche Allergien oder
Unfertiglichkeiten bekannt?
Nein. Okay, Herr Holt.
Jetzt bin ich mit den Fragen fertig.
Möchten Sie etwas fragen
oder hinzufügen?
Ich möchte wissen, ob Sie mir helfen können,
ob die Luftball besser wird
oder was waren Sie,
warum ich Luftnot habe
und dass es immer schlimmer wird.
Und Stunde durch Stunde wird schlimmer?
Ja, ich werde hier
die Situation
gut, Herr Holt, aber es ist zu früh,
etwas Konkretes zu sagen.
Ich werde zuerst Sie
Körperdurch untersuchen
oder ich werde Ihnen Blut ab
und ich veranlasse
für Sie eine EKG-Ultre-Suchung
und eine Röntgenaufnahme
von Ihrem Buskord.
Und dann können wir
genauer besprechen.
Okay.
Es gibt noch einige Fragen vom Chat.
So, mal kurz reingehen.
Ja.
So, wo haben wir angefangen?
Mit 28 Jahren
hat er wirklich zu OPD
kann sein.
Hat der Fieber kein
Auswurf, haben Sie gefragt?
Hat Husten oder keinen Auswurf?
Ne, hat er nichts.
Hatten Sie einen Unfall?
Kein Unfall.
Eine gute Frage, ja.
Wie sind die Buschmerzen?
Ja, das kann man fragen
und...
Wie viele Schmerzen sind?
Bitte.
Ja, das ist eine wichtige Frage, ja.
Also Schmerzen sind, wenn Sie die Skala nehmen,
10.
Ja, auf der rechten Seite hier.
Die Skala und die Schmerzen
sind aus.
Die Schmerzen sparen nicht aus, nein.
Die Primäre...
Ich sponte eine Primaturax, aber...
Ja, nicht so schnell.
Wir machen erstmal die Fragen.
Ja.
Nachtschweiß hat er nichts.
Haben Sie gefragt, glaube ich,
Geruchsstörung, Geruchsstörung, ne?
Geruchsstörung hat er nicht
eine Corona-Fragenziege.
Hat er stundenlang gereist,
also Flugreise, nein.
Ist Ihre Luftnot atemabhängig?
Ja, also der kann nicht tief einatmen.
Aber sonst hat er durchgehend
Luftnot.
Strahlende Schmerzen aus, haben wir schon gefragt.
Seit wann haben die Schmerzen?
Seit heute Morgen, ja, das sind wichtige Fragen, ja.
Okay, was gibt es noch?
Sind Sie Schädigungsstoffen
bei der Arbeitsausgesetzt?
Weiß er nicht.
Er ist Mechaniker, hat da so verschiedene Stoffe, aber...
Kann sein, ja, gute Frage.
Okay.
Was hätten Sie noch gefragt?
Eigentlich haben wir Schwelden...
Ja, vorher.
Ja, also das ist ein guter Hinweis.
Brustschmerz, Luftnot, Schwarzveraugen.
In solchen Schwellen sollte man direkt
Monitor anschließen, ja.
Man sollte direkt Sättigung messen bei den Patienten.
Und direkt nicht ergeben machen, ist auch gut, ja.
Ja.
Weil sich die Patienten schnell verstechnen können.
Also EKG kann man vielleicht noch ein paar Minuten verzögern.
Aber ich würde sofort Monitor, also Kreisstrahlüberwachung
und Sättigung messen bei solchen Patienten, die
Luftnote haben, ja.
Sollten Sie bei der anderen Nese auch sagen,
dass Sie, okay, jetzt kriegen Sauerstoff,
und wir schließen Sie mal an und messen mal die Sauerstoff-
Sättigung. Das würde ich machen, ja.
Haben Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt?
Gute Frage. Hat er nicht gehabt?
Kurzoxymetrie haben wir gesagt, ja.
Diese eine Frage
hat er stundenlang gereist.
Also im Flugreis und so was, ja.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Was kann man daran noch anschließen?
Was für eine Frage?
Das geht ja in eine bestimmte Richtung,
wenn die Fragen, zum Beispiel Lungenboli, ja.
Was kann man noch fragen bei Lungenboli?
Schmerzen im Unterschenkel gibt es Schmerzen.
Zum Beispiel, ja.
Schmerzunterschwellung im Bein-Unterschinkel-Bereich, ja.
Ja.
Das würde ich auch fragen, ja.
Gut.
Was noch?
Sonst haben wir das wichtigste gefragt, ja.
Sind die Schmerzen belastungabhängig
oder auch im Ruhe?
Er kann sich nicht belasten.
Er hat eine Ruhe, schon Luftnot.
Also Ruhe, das ist mühe, ja.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Dann haben wir, glaube ich, die wichtigsten Fragen
und jetzt stellen Sie dem Oberarzt vor.
Myokarditis,
das ist die Differenzialdiagnose.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose bei den Patienten?
Ja, ich würde sagen,
auch spontan bin ich ein Motorax.
Ja, richtig.
Und differenzial diagnostisch
kommen Myokarditis
oder Pleurorheurus
in Frage.
Pleurorheurus macht normalerweise
nicht so stark geschmeißen,
wenn überhaupt, ja.
Aber eine haben wir genannt,
die Lungenemboli, ja.
Das ist ein wichtiger Drillen-Mona-Diagnose.
Lungenemboli, ja.
Das war jetzt nicht das typische Patientenkollektiv,
aber kann trotzdem mal sein, ja.
Also spontan bin ich ein Motorax, ist richtig.
Das war die Diagnose von Patienten.
Warum müssen Sie da so ein bisschen aufpassen?
Warum ich so ein bisschen versucht habe,
zu sagen, dass der Patient Luftnot hat und so weiter, ja.
Und schwarz vor Augen wird,
dass er schlechter wird,
von Stunde zu Stunde.
Was kann da nämlich passieren,
als Komplikation?
Vielleicht schon.
Ja, das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt.
Vielleicht
Tier- oder Schlaganfall?
Vielleicht.
Kann auch, aber das ist das gefährliche Ampnomotorax.
Wenn es schlechter wird,
von Minute zu Minute.
Anzion Pneomotorax?
Ja, wie nennt man es auf Deutsch?
Was ist Anzion?
Nicht Bluthochbox, sondern...
Duruk, oder?
Spannungspneomotorax.
Was passiert dabei,
bei Spannungspneomotorax?
Was passiert da?
Kollaps.
Kollaps ist bei Pneomotorax immer.
Aber was ist das gefährlich
bei Spannungspneomotorax?
Es läuft Depression.
Warum?
Es ist
karkidisptive
...
Warum ist das so gefährlich, Spannungspneu?
Ist das gefährlich?
Ja, gefährlich.
Es ist ein Notfall, wenn es hier ist ein Notfall.
Wir müssen sofort intervenieren.
Ja, aber
wie kommt das Patrophysiologen mit?
Alle Organe
einer Seite
in einer Seite.
Ja, genau.
Ja, das kommt dann
mit Diastnalschift,
mit Verlegung der Gochete.
Ja, richtig.
Aber bei jeder Atmung
kommt mehr Luft rein,
das wird immer mehr nach zur Leiter verschoben.
Ja, richtig.
Gut, aber
bevor Sie Oberst vorstellen,
ich will mal kurz gucken, was hier noch ein Kommentar ist.
Luft geht nicht raus.
Corona-Impfung
hat es etwas mit Corona zu tun?
Ich glaube nicht.
Das war nur so eine Irreführung.
Eigentlich wollte ich sagen,
ich bin in Wirkung von Impfung
mit York-RTX.
Kann sein, ja.
Oder auch Nebenwirkung von Impfung
kaum bei Embollie gibt es ja,
vielleicht könnte sein.
Aber nach 2 Wochen
ist es sehr unwahrscheinlich, zu spät.
Gut, ok, dann
kommen wir zur Oberarztvorstellung, ja.
Ja, ok.
Bitte schön.
Was haben Sie gesagt schon?
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Guten Tag.
Ich möchte Ihnen
einen neuen Patient vorstellen.
Ich habe eine kurze Zeit dafür.
Der Patient heißt
Thomas Holtz.
Er ist 28 Jahre alt.
Er ist Abtomekaniker
vom Beruf.
Er ist ledig und hat keine Kinder.
Er kam heute zu uns.
Wir gehen seit
heute Morgen
vor 3 Stunden
aufgetretenen
starke
torokalsche Märzen
und dyspneu
und
tussis.
Sagen Sie,
tussis nutzt man nicht in Deutschland.
Ja, ok.
Und husten.
Es
wurde ihm
es wurde ihm
auch schwarz vor Augen.
Und während
der Anamnesegespräch
war es
sehr
kompakt.
Nach ein paar Minuten
konnten wir weiter machen.
Haben Sie die Veranstaltung
gemessen?
Haben Sie das gemacht?
Ja, ich habe es auch gemacht.
Sagen Sie,
das geht nicht.
Sonst können Sie keine Anamnese machen.
Das müssen Sie gleich arbeiten.
Das sind die 2,92
Kreisverfassungsstätten.
sagen wir uns gemessen 92 kreisdorf stabil deswegen habe ich mit einem mese weitergemacht ja
vor zwei wochen hat er erste dose von koronavir von gehabt
er sagt er hat gesagt dass er auch takyukardi hat er hat kein andere bescheiden
an wesentliche vorerkrankungen leidet er seit vier fünf jahren
lungen empfüllen und er nimmt eine inhalation ich habe das medikament einmal morgens
und familienhamnese ergab vater ist an bronchial kartsnom mit 62 jahren verstorben und
mutter leidet auch unter zu pd und arterielle hypotonie und er hat kein fieber entschuldigung
die vegetative anhamnese ist unaufhörlich psychische anhamnese ergab er hat stress wegen
aktölem bescheiden als medikamente nimmt er nur spür über ergibt einen nicotine konsum von
von zwölf jahrelang ein zwei pechentäglich hat einen gelingendlichen alkohol konsum
und in der jügenzeit hat er Drogen probiert sonst nimmt er keine Drogen ist keine allergie er hat
keine allergie ja die anhamnestische angaben der den amnesten auf ein spontan pneumatrags
hin ja weil der patient stark rauher ist ist 28 jahrel die disney und restzeit gebrüchen
hat plötzlich angefangen ja differenzial diagnostisch kommen
mio karditis oder lingon emboli in betracht okay gibt es sonst aus der anhamnese noch hinweise
dass es die urser an spontan pneumatrag sein könnte was hat er vorall krank haben sie gesagt
ja das kann ein risikofaktör sein ja wenn nun bläßchen groß sind so bulle die können
platzen mal ja kann sein ja genau ja sie haben den haben sie den patient untersucht klinik oder
wie können sie feststellen ob es an pneumatrags klinik klinik ja beide auskultation der lunge kann
man kann man hören die lunge geräusche man kann man nicht kann ja auf dieser seite auf dieser seite
kann man fast nichts hören ja okay ja nennt man dann wie wenn man das beschreibt wenn sie
beschreiben sie haben auskultation doppelpunkt das bereuen sie ich glaube ich die seite sie
hören ja nach einem atemgeräusch ja man könnte sagen oder fast keine
geräusche oder abgeschwächtes atemgeräusch ja genau und wenn sie
den geräusche hören ist am pneumatrags ausgeschlossen nein nicht ausgeschlossen ja okay wo wo
auskultieren auskultieren sie denn insbesondere wenn sie den verdacht auf ein pneumatrags
haben welchen bereich müssen sie genau achten beim auskultieren rechten unten
da machten sie besonders drauf ja ist nicht rechts oben luft geht nach oben schwer kraft
ja ja also man muss man manchmal machen kann wenn sie normales atemgeräusch hören
dass die stethoscope hier drauf legen hier oben und einem seiten tag gleich gucken wenn hier
auf der rechten seite nicht zu hören ist und hier links zu hören ist dann ist auch hier apical
ab neu meistens der neu apical also hier auskultieren hier oben ja super glaviculare grober bei lung
impräsent Patienten ist es ja sehr oft dass hier sehr hoch hohe lungenspitze haben ja also hier
oben auskultieren okay sie haben auskultiert das gibt es noch für möglichkeiten klinik
einen pneumatrags festzustellen auskultation dann macht man noch was anderes an der lunge
das macht man noch perktion abgelaufen wie ist er befunden bei pneumatrags wenn sie
perkutieren es gibt typanete kann man sagen ja kann man sagen ja also wie ist der klopfschall normal
bei dem normalen patzen wenn sie klopfen wie ist der dann wie beschreibt man den ich weiß nicht
normale bei sagt man so nur klopfschall so nur ja so nur und wenn der klopfschall so wie
schenkel ist dann ist er dann ist er gedämpft und wie ist es wenn ein pneumatrags da ist der klopfschall
hat jemand schon geschrieben ja wie personell klopfschall genau ja also grad zur beschreibung
von von auskultations befunden wenn man einen kurzgefunden schreibt in den akte dann macht
man meistens so ich schreibe immer so pull mode doppeltpunkt ja dann kann sich schreiben atemgeräusch
bei normalen von vesiculär oder von mir aus abgeschwärcht oder aufgehoben beim pneumatrags
klopfschall so nur dann kann man auch wenn man will noch die verschieblichkeit bestimmt und so
weiter aber diese beiden sachen sollten gründ sein ja klopfschall und atemgeräusch ja beim
pneumatrags atemgeräusch aufgehoben und vermindert und klopfschall hypersornur genau gut
jetzt haben sie das gemacht aber klinik konnt sie das nicht feststellen was gibt es noch für
möglichkeiten haben sich schon gesagt was machen sie als nächstes ganz gute spezialisten können
auch pyrmotrags anders feststellen nicht ganz nicht muss ich alles sagen ich finde schwierig aber
und kann es auch einfacher glaube ich und kann torax ja und ja wenn sie das gemacht haben
und torax ist da was in der luft und was machen sie dann als nächstes brust üb einlegen ja
nennt man das ich weiß das auch nicht genau torax drainage torax drainage oder auch
im deutschland auch auf bühler drainage genannt ja bühler drainage ja ok und wo legen sie die
bühler drainage an die sind jetzt sind jetzt notarzt und müssen anlegen wo legt man das
normalerweise an normalerweise recht der raterall legion und welche rippe
unter der siebte rippe oder normalerweise macht man immer also loko typico ist zweite rippe
zweite rippe jetzt zweite icr medioclavikularlinie ja das büblich aber manchmal
hin nach dem wieder neu auch ist kann man auch andere stellen nach so ein ja richtig ja gut
jetzt hat jemand im kommentar genannt wichtig wenn sie ein röntgenbild anfordern soll müssen
die drauf schreiben oder manchmal müssen drauf schreiben röntgen in expiration weil damit
der der der pyrmotrags besser zu sehen ist ja wenn die patien experimenten aber wenn es
ein großer pneus ist egal eigentlich haben sie wenn sie auch beim normalen röntgen sehr gut ok gut
aber sie haben noch eine differentialdiagnose genannt die die myocarditis oder lungembolli
was würden sie dann dazu machen wenn sie jetzt klinisch und im röntgen kein pnomotorx gesehen
haben das machen sie dann der parallel kann man ja manchmal machen für mich
ökarditis oder eine mich ökarditis also schließen und auch herzenfackeln die
differentialdiagnose ja ekg auf jeden fall ekg weil der patient trockerschmerzen hat
und wenn es möglich ist ein echo und bei labor entzündungsparameter und der die mehr
lungen im bolli richtig ja und wegen herzen was machen sie noch labor herzen
natürlich genau genau troponin in zp ok und wenn es auch alles unaufwändig ist was machen
sie dann alles noch aufhörlich ok ja ct torax ja weil in röntgen torax kann man
auch ein pnomotorx verpassen gibt es manchmal ja so ich dir ja und was kann man im ct noch gut
erkennen dann die differentialdiagnose genannt haben lungen die lungembolli müssen
angio ct also ct mit kontast mittel dann ja angio ct dann haben sie auch die
die ja ja was kann nochmal in selten fällen sein für einen toer kalle schmerz
eigenes ja kein herzenfackel kann lungen bolli kein pnomotorx gibt man so
ein seltene problem bei junges sehr selten aber bei älteren patzen kann es mal geben
stärkste schmerzen toer kahl decken sie an die orta am leutos
die sektion haben wir selten sein herbst soster kann auch weh tun aber
meist nicht so stark normalerweise ja genau ok gut geht es dazu noch fragen
kommentare sonst haben wir glaube ich alles wichtige gefragt und gesagt auch
ja also die anemese war auch gut vorstellung war auch sehr gut das einzige was ich empfehlen
würde es kann sein dass die ich weiß nicht wie es in der prüfung ist da gibt es ja simulations
paten manchmal habe ich gehört oder gibt es die nicht ja aber solcher solcher simulation habe ich
noch nie gehabt ich meine während der anemnese ja ich habe von anderen gehört dass den
paten so notwendig kommen dass sie halt darauf achten dass sie sagen zum Beispiel so zauerstoff und
monitor aber das würde ich machen mit paten so sehr dringend das ist eine wichtig das kann
sein dass sie das dann sagen sie haben spontan mit dem motorx eine stunde lang an der messe
gemacht paten ist bei ihnen gestorben bei der anemnese ja das soll nicht passieren ja ja